- [Man] The year was 1946.
Radio was king, and The
Adventures of Superman
ruled the airwaves.
But with fascism vanquished,
the Man of Steel set his
sights on a different foe.
This is the story of how
Superman busted the Ku Klux Klan.
- Because unless we stop
this fiery cross clan now,
they'll get you no matter where you go.
- [Man] The story starts
with Stetson Kennedy,
a journalist who infiltrated the Klan
for the Anti-Defamation League.
- [Rick] He wanted to
melt the cultural glue
that held the Klan together.
- [Man] Thanks, Rick.
- [Rick] No problem.
- That's Rick Bowers.
- B-O-W-
- [Man] He wrote this book.
- [Rick] Superman Versus The Ku Klux Klan.
- [Man] But what does Stetson Kennedy
have to do with Superman?
Remember, the Last Son of
Krypton needed a new enemy.
- [Rick] The producers of the radio show,
on a very bold gambit,
decided Superman would take
on real-life hate groups.
(upbeat music)
- [Man] The creators of
The Adventures of Superman
used Kennedy's research to
produce a 16-part series called
The Clan of the Fiery Cross.
- The Clan of the Fiery Cross,
where a great secret society
pledged to purify America.
- [Rick] The Superman producers went
to the Anti-Defamation League, and said,
"Authenticate our script,
provide us more information."
- [Second Man] It was a
way to get the message out
that no one else could get out
just by telling horror stories.
- I am the Grand Scorpion of
the Clan of the Fiery Cross.
- The Grand Rat, you mean!
- [Rick] It exposed the
Clan as hate-mongers,
but it also exposed the Clan
as a money-driven organization.
- I'm running a business,
Rigs, and so are you!
We deal in one of the oldest
and most profitable commodities on earth.
Hate.
- [Rick] It was a break-through
in American broadcasting.
Not only had they done
this great public service,
but they elevated themselves
to the number one radio
show for kids on air.
- Well they're cowardly
gangsters who operate at night,
hidden behind sheets and hoods.
Their minds are diseased with hate.
No one is safe from them.
- [Man] I guess you could say
that the white robes stood no chance
against the Man of Steel.
(upbeat music)